if this guy steps out on the porch
and you know we give him commands of
surrender and he doesn't do that if he
turns to go back inside the house
drop him literally that's it you know
you are authorized to put this guy down
[Music]
what's up brother howard hey man what is
happening sean nothing we are going to
run down another episode here of
cocktails and cocktails with just the
two of us it's uh
we've done one and it was a blast it was
easy to do you know why because we when
i when i talk to you on the phone i'm
always asking you cop shit that you are
and you're always asking me how you can
like beauty tips that that i am
and how i have such a lustrous head of
hair and
this facial hair of god so correct and
this is uh you're probably using bear
grease on it okay i probably would i
would you know that comes from heating
oil
i liked having him on a lot but hey so
but we're always we're always talking
about this stuff so and it's pretty
interesting we get these long
conversations and we talk about current
events things that have happened things
are pretty funny
so
we should just do an episode that was
the idea of how this whole podcast came
about basically right we were born in a
car going across pennsylvania for four
days buying booze
pennsylvania you do have a pretty state
by the way you do have a very long stay
very very long lengthy were we six hours
uh
yeah something like that it just kept
going and going and where where was the
place we ate at cracker barrel cracker
barrel no cracker was cracker barrel in
pennsylvania
yeah dude we had a cracker barrel a
couple times maybe we stopped somewhere
at night and they was it like burger
king no no we tried to find some place
to eat at past ten o'clock and all that
we could find was burger king okay yeah
so we ended up eating it at chipotle
chipotle all right never go wrong with
chipotle yeah they're not a sponsor but
if you've got to be a sponsor we're here
for you chipotle i eat the shit out of
your food you should sponsor us you can
pay us a gift cards
i'll take that yeah me too absolutely i
like the double chicken it's good all
right let's get this on so today on this
episode of podcast we are going to drink
a lovely
1792
uh speaking of that trip we went to this
distillery and did a tour there yeah and
uh i know you will remember this but i'm
going to ask you anyways i did not know
this i had bottles of 1792. there are
several different ones but the sweet
wheat is probably my one of my favorites
the 12 year the full proof for good ones
also
but
uh why are they called 1792 damn i
forgot
i asked this on the deal or maybe they
said it but that is the year that
kentucky became a state ah so a little
history here for everybody listening you
get history as well as comedy and police
knowledge we're basically a we're like
school we're pretty much an encyclopedia
britannica all right so man we always uh
i got a few things that i'm gonna bring
up and one of the things that you and i
that's cheers wow oh yeah cheers
while we get
hold on i gotta drink this
uh why we get along so well is that we
have the same um
moms
that's not what your dad said um
the um
same sense of humor right that is true
and one of the things that we find funny
is we find certain comedians we're like
oh damn that guy is spot-on he's very
very very funny i love a good comedian
and one
one of the comedians that i like a lot
and then i quote quite a bit is um kat
williams that you do and i was talking
about cat williams talking about smoking
weed and weeds gotten very strong as of
late he doesn't like smoking the weed
that is very strong as of late he's a
little fella yeah have you seen actually
just on a side deal here have you seen
the video where he fights like a seventh
grader that puts him on his ass yeah i
saw that he's okay yeah he gets put down
yeah but
but he's always talking about he goes i
don't need thriller killer i just need
regular wii so i was talking about that
and you said hey man dave have you seen
the one where he's talking about tank
tank
i'm like
no and he goes you gotta watch the one
about tink tank so of course you send me
a video i'll watch it i was like holy
shit that's fuck that is fucking
hilarious comedy genius yeah so it is
well
so
when he was referring to tink tank who's
he referring to he's referring to the
former uh was the olympic runner i mean
perry olympia paralympian right uh it
was a pistorius i think is how his name
is pronounced if i remember correctly uh
oscar pastorius i believe was what it
was but he was a uh
i mean he was a track star yeah that was
missing his legs basically from his
knees down
and he had um i don't know what they're
called i mean they're some sort of a
prosthetic well do you know what that
you're a medical guy what what exactly
are those those are prosthetics reverse
camber legs there you go reverse
cambered legs but in the comedy stand-up
um they're made out of metal
he talked about him having to race
against regular people regular legs and
he called him a little tink tank because
of his legs when he's like ding ding
ding ding ding ding when he's running
and i think he called him bent back
paper
clips mean it is literally one of the
funniest uh this is very funny it is a
funny funny segment we should plug in a
clip here i agree for anybody yes if if
we can't plug this thing in go to
youtube bunch in just poor little tink
tank right and you'll find it's an old
clip i mean it's got to be at least 10
plus years old probably well with the
name like oscar pistorius he was not
from america he was from australia yeah
and he was
is i mean he went to prison yeah you
know what he went to prison for was it a
murder uh yeah or like uh he shot his
girlfriend through the door and tried to
say his accident yeah like he thought
somebody was attacking her there so he
shot through the door he ended up
killing her well they didn't buy and
they uh sentenced him um to 13 years in
prison okay
well he's up for parole right now and
he's pissed because the family is
slowing down his parole and they're
talking about i guess this is in
australia maybe do we have anything
similar to this this is why i'm asking
this question it's called victim
offender dialogue where the victim's
family gets to come in they get to talk
to the parole board and say hey can we
release this bastard or not yeah we we
do have that so it's like a victim
impact statement um even you know it's
times it's done at the the conclusion of
a trial where there's a conviction um
you know as part of the sentencing and
then when people come up for parole
you know let's say
you know a crime something like that
here in at least oklahoma it's what we
call an 85 percent crime so you get
we'll just say 10-year sentence you have
to do 85
of that sentence before you're eligible
for parole
um and so even if you're being a good
good lad inside prison and taking
classes and not getting in trouble you
still have to serve 85 percent until
you're up for parole and then when you
come up for pro they're going to look at
you know were you getting in trouble why
you were locked up
are you doing the programming whether
it's substance abuse mental health you
know things like that getting your ged
if you need to and so forth but they do
have
everything from
victims families
to
police officers prosecutors and stuff
like that that can go to the parole
hearing and
give their opinion if they think this
person should be out you ever been to
one i have not you know any caps that
have been
you know not not cops it's not something
typically police officers do i mean it's
just not that's shit you see in the
movies where the guy's like oh yeah they
said prosecutors you know they're the
ones that will
you know uh someone from the district
attorney's office if somebody does go
will be that but oftentimes it is it's
victims families or victims themselves
especially if you're talking you know
child abuse sexual assault and things
like that and they're the victims that
go and talk about the impact that this
person had on their life with their
crimes
yeah that's awful so i'm glad that the
families get a say in that sure
absolutely all right so we just uh
there's a couple things guess we also
got uh released from prison this week
i do not know a very famous man named
john hinckley john hinckley old school
case yeah yeah that's awesome
he shot president reagan he did and it
was all over a girl right
that i didn't know it was over jody
foster
i didn't know he was right yeah that's
how he was trying to get jody foster
little did we know that jody foster was
not interested in him or any other guy
yes that's true yeah well you know
there are a lot of girls
that do like
gangsters
that like bad guys so you know maybe he
was thinking she would be down for it
but he got out today all right so the
one thing i also wanted to talk about is
that something happening i kind of i'm
on social media just like everybody else
and one of my favorite social media
sites to follow
is the tulsa police department yeah and
you can follow them on facebook if
anybody would like to follow them they
have some wonderful stories on that
they're on twitter i know that they are
on twitter hey we've got a twitter story
coming up too
so
um this week on there they had a
gentleman who and a girl who committed a
murder
and then called an uber
yes and the uber picked him up as the
police were coming up this is some shit
like out of a movie this is called
leaving a trail right the um they told
the uber driver to get on with it they
didn't threaten him or anything but they
ducked down in the back of the police
car
of the police car or the of the uber
okay so the police wouldn't see him
so
what's the impact on the uber driver
from doing this what how how should an
uber driver handle this
um
let's see if i was and someone laid down
in the back seat yeah now does the uber
driver at this point know that they're
armed or committed to murder no i don't
so they're just laying down i've laid
down the backseat of the movers but it's
that was two or three o'clock in the
morning after out having cocktails right
and they'll wake you up they will they
will wake you up
i don't know do tell me i don't know i
could come up with some jokes but i
don't know well come up with the jokes
then we'll hear the jokes well i'll say
you know
you know if it's a guy and girl laying
back there you know do you tilt the
mirror back and try to see what's going
on you go find him a secluded spot and
step outside the car and smoke a
cigarette
uh you know if you think
that something's a foot you know some
crime going on do you
go you know crash test dummy and crash
into something and let them cold
launching out of the back seat i don't
know well from my understanding here's
what the uber did he went ahead and
finished the fair because he didn't want
to fuck up that five star rating did
that five star rating that tip that's
what tip your uber drivers 25 percent
then he contacted the police and said
hey um i delivered some people to this
address you might want to come over here
and find him which
is kind of he protected himself i mean
if i was in that position i would kind
of like i gotta get these people out of
my car absolutely so protect himself
play dumb yeah and then as a good
citizen which we need good citizens
right
he called the cops cops came over so did
he know that something had already
happened or yeah because he saw them
ducking from the cops as they went past
the cops okay that makes sense man i'm
uh so back in golly 2002
or so something like that i was in a
unit called the major crimes homicide
unit
and uh one night
my sergeant at time was a guy by the
name of tim bracken uh one of the guys i
worked with was a guy by the name of
glenn youren who to this day is one of
the funniest policemen i've ever worked
around
but we had gotten a call to an apartment
over in east tulsa kind of near 21st
memorial area for a homicide
and we had gone in there and
shown up there to investigate it and the
guy
was
dead as
dead as you know dead dead dead laying
on his back right inside the front door
of his apartment
and what had happened was this guy was a
photographer here in tulsa
and he had taken some pictures of a
woman at her request and her boyfriend
found out about it and thought there was
something going on between the two of
them so he showed up over there
knocked on the door dude open the door
and just shot him multiple times right
there at the door boom drops back dead
well
the suspect took a cab there this is pre
uber obviously back in 02 or so
so he took a cab
and had the cab wait out there while he
did this in the you know he got out
another part of the apartment complex
walked over shoots this guy runs back
jumps in the cabin takes off well he's
shit-faced drunk during this whole time
and as he's driving back northbound on
memorial
he is just causing a problem in the cab
and so the cab driver pulls over used to
be a old phillips 66 at admiral memorial
and he kicks the cab driver into the
fair there and kicks the guy out okay
this goes back to the the thing we say
all the time you know you don't catch
the smart ones
so while he is there at the phillips 66
he's drunk and starts causing a problem
there at the phillips 66 and the gas
station attendant calls the police
because this guy's being a drunk asshole
and the cops show up and arrest him for
a public drunk
all that's happening while we get called
out to the homicide while we're working
a homicide we figured out like an hour
or two later hey this idiot just got
arrested for being drunk you know you
get the cab driver and all that so
just a old story from 20 plus years ago
well you know what's amazing about that
he was able to get a cab
do you remember how hard it was to get a
cab around tulsa isn't like new york
city yeah there's not cabs that you just
you know stand out in the street corner
and put your hand up and get get a cab
that's
tulsa is not like that you have to call
pre uber you had to call for him or you
have to have the guy at the bar call for
him if your cell phone was dead and then
it was about a
20 80
mix 80 not getting a cab 20 getting a
cab so you'd take a little chance you'd
wait about an hour and then you'd end up
walking to wherever you were going yep
so i'm just i'm just shocked that he got
a cab to begin with
okay so you we we were having a
conversation this weekend and you um you
were like hey dude did you watch the bad
vegan and i was like no what's it about
so you went ahead and told me about the
bad vegan and i started watching did you
watch it how many of you watched so far
dude it got fucking depressing about the
third one i was just like i don't know
if it was so depressing or
it
what was going on what she said
was so depressing to me or i was like
how in the hell are you so goddamn
stupid absolutely yeah and i i had to
turn it off so i've watched um you got
to finish it there's only four episodes
right i watched two and three quarters
of it but it
when the whole like metaphysical all the
fanciful thing fanciful
i didn't go so i stopped that one
and i started watching this other one
and it was
so so before you go onto that i want to
say bad vegan is a documentary that is
on netflix right now it's four episodes
long
um
basically this woman that owns a very
popular vegan restaurant in new york
city
or did own one in new york city and her
and her
lion ass boyfriend um
basically no they got married dude oh
yeah you're right they did they got
married you're right so they the dude
she ends up meeting she just got skipped
he was just a con man yeah a hundred
percent she was listen i wanna if you
know if you're interested it's a good
documentary to watch i thought it was uh
more than anything you get baffled how
people
get i'm going to use the word bamboozled
or brainwashed
she was a yeah but she has no you didn't
finish it but i'm telling you the woman
accepts no responsibility for her parts
and that that's what pisses me off too
it's like hey yeah you might have got uh
you know
suckered into this guy but you need to
accept some responsibility for the shit
you did too but good documentary yeah
anyways okay so you went on to what so i
i was like all right some butt head yeah
yeah
you look a lot like fucking davis i know
you brought that up too cool um
so i went on and was watching another
documentary which took me down a rabbit
hole so you and i like to play call of
duty right big call of duty fan we're uh
we're we're big uh hardcore kill
confirmed players that's it's the only
way to play it doesn't make sense to get
shot and somehow not die yeah it's not
realistic i mean if we're going to play
video games we want to look pretty
realistic absolutely so people who don't
know anything about call of duty let's
give them a little bit of a rundown well
it's what i call first of all on a
personal level i call it my dumb down
time right it takes no thinking it takes
no thinking that's where i'm not
thinking about life or kids or bills or
work or whatever it may be you just kind
of focus there
you zone out with a bunch of people
probably ages 12 to 50-ish if you're
getting beat they're 12 yeah and they
talk shit too
but uh you know it's a what do they call
it a first-person shooter shoot a game
it's a war game and
different maps different guns different
tools and so forth so when the and it's
extremely popular oh yeah huge huge i
think franchise yeah i think the call of
duty franchise has something around 300
million subscribers that pay monthly to
i may be off on my numbers there but
it's huge yeah
i wouldn't be surprised between that and
sales i mean i don't know if they don't
know if they're a billion dollar
enterprise or whatever but it's a lot of
money but they um we play with other
people online like you and i can play
together we've played together before we
played all pistol games we've done some
of that stuff i play by myself sometimes
you do
since i was 14
since it started
but with that said you play with other
people online we play a game called kill
confirm which is
you if you shoot somebody they drop a
tag and you have to go pick the tag up
or it doesn't really count right red is
for you know that you're trying to get
to 65 tags yeah you're ready red is the
opposite team you're trying to collect
if there's a blue tag that's one of the
homies that got killed one of your
buddies right and you got to go you want
to go to the tag tonight you want to go
get that so the other team doesn't get
it right and we play this hardcore so it
basically means that instead of having
to shoot somebody 90 times you shoot
them a couple times and they fall over
correct so we play that and
we talk shit as well of course and we'll
have great games where we'll play and
we'll let's say for example we'll end up
with 25 tags and we'll only get killed
like four times and then we'll have
games that we get
vice versa yeah it just flips and i do
want to
disclaimer i don't talk shit until
people start talking shit i'm not
automatic i don't i don't initiate that
no i don't either okay all right just
want to make sure everyone's aware of
that but we look a lot like if you want
to play them stixx721
on the xbox sti cks721
and i am stinky ponies if you're so
inclined to play with me on the xbox
but it gets kind of frustrating at times
even though this is our downtime we get
aggravated we're like
what
i played today
and you get mad at yourself oh yeah you
do you get the stress level goes up i
don't know why but it does
so
there are people that are very good at
this correct a lot of gamers online
there's gamers that are extremely
popular people that make money right
playing well some of these streams some
of these streamers are as popular as
this podcast
some of them even a little bit world
famous evidently yeah i'm telling you
they are fucking something so we've got
some of these streamers out there but
there's a lot of guys that are like us
just old and not very handsome right but
we can go on and we can do these uh
matches where we have a custom match and
we can have a bet on it
right so i'm like okay this is
i've heard about these
well i was watching this documentary and
it started talking about this thing
called swatting have you heard of this
uh i was on the swat team was i'm well
aware of swat stuff yeah but do you know
what swatting is i do
i had no idea why didn't you ever tell
me about this first of all okay okay
hold on i'm sure we ran the definition
of swatting there is
anybody that does swat is in special
weapons and tactics that term is not
used so
um they're swatting you know kind of old
school you know grandma's gonna swatch
you when you've been in trouble
there's probably swatting that goes on
in the
privacy of
two adults consenting to two adults or
something in their bedroom or more
whatever you're into if you're into odd
numbers
threes and stuff like that but
um some swatting that might take place
there
and then there's the swatting of
basically somebody calls in a situation
to somebody else's residence typically
and it gets the police to show up out
there with the police thinking they're
coming to some sort of emergency
well i had no clue this shit existed
until i
i heard this term and i've gone down a
rabbit hole on it so one of the most
famous he called himself like the king
of swatters
was on twitter and he was known he was a
gentleman that was known for uh calling
him bomb threats
to elementary schools in southern
california messed up uh he lived in
california so he did a lot of things
things around california he would also
call uh
into residences or people that had beef
with him online yeah yep and he would
call in like if he got if he got in an
argument with somebody online somebody
was trolling him he would figure out
what their address was which that's
called doxing yep so i'm learning all
these new terms not to be confused with
docking yeah that's completely
between that one that's on urban
dictionary don't don't find that one on
there so
we will not demonstrate documents no we
will not not at all so what
what transpired is this guy ended up he
was living with his grandmother he's
doing these uh swatting attacks on
people there's your first clue right
there this guy is living with his
grandmother yeah at what age do we know
probably he was 18 19. okay all right
he was pretty much raised by his
grandmother all right all right but he
uh he got bored with just making these
bomb threats at elementary schools
because you know that's not very
exciting so he thought you know what i'm
going to do
a bomb threat at the news station and
have them cover it live because he goes
oh that's what i wanted well while he
was doing this and you ask how is he
able to do this from like his grandma's
phone how is he doing this from his
grandmother well he wasn't i mean kids
are a little more sophisticated with
computers than we are so they were using
that uh voip stuff voiceover internet
protocol
so he was routing it looked like
something like jason bourne but he was
while he was doing this his room his
grandmother overheard what was going on
went outside into the living room and
noticed that there was a bomb threat
and made a correlation so she told
her son he she goes or her grandson i
know you've done this to which he
responded back
yes i've done this and if you tell
anybody i will fucking kill you to his
grandmother so well obviously not very
stable he's not going to be in the will
right so what did grandma do grandma
don't take nothing she beat that ass i
hope no grandma don't take no shit she
called the cops and swatted him
so he got end up put in jail she had a
restraining order against him he
couldn't go back so in order to support
himself when he got out of jail he used
his skills to swat people for hire
and you ask well how much how much do
you charge for it swati how much would
one charge for such a thing well you
would charge 10 to 15 depending on how
complex the swat was
and here's what's fucked up about it
dude you know this if you have a fake
call like a bomb threat or you have a
call that there's a domestic violence
somebody's killing it you send out the
swat team well that's a
i mean i know we're making light of the
situation but from a resource standpoint
you are tying up police officers
you know from other calls that could be
on especially if it is in fact a bomb
squad call so you're you're calling out
bomb squad guys um you know it's costing
the city money for overtime the
resources
if it's a
swat team type of call
that they have to go to again you're
pulling
you know officers from other places that
they're doing their job other things
they're involved with you know whether
they're off duty with their family and
stuff like that you're pulling people
away
you know for something and they're going
to somebody's house a school a business
that nothing wrong is going on and all
sudden they've got this large police
presence
and it causes panic
you know a lot of fear and stuff like
that and because
i was had a lengthy police career i have
a lot of stories
when i was a brand new police supervisor
we don't we've only fortunately only had
a handful of those type of calls in
tulsa that i'm aware of one of them
which happened when i was a new police
supervisor and it was actually not too
far from your old place
it was somewhere around maybe like 12 15
in lewis area or something like that
over in that area if i remember
correctly
and a call was coming in from somebody
whispering that was saying they were
they were a female
and that their dad had just killed i
think their mom and like their little
brother or their little sister or
something
and this person was whispering the whole
time saying they were hiding underneath
the bed in their house
and was saying you know my dad doesn't
know i'm here he's walking around the
house he's got a gun he's killed these
people and gave an address
so we're all taking off going there
and we get over to the place and i mean
i was a brand new supervisor this is
back in 0.506 something like that
and we're basically setting up a
perimeter and at this point
the dispatcher still has the person on
the on the call and you know we get the
address obviously we don't want to set
up with the wrong address so we're
trying to verify
through the dispatcher who's talking to
the person on the phone that this is in
fact the correct address so we're trying
to get numbers to the house in the
street we're trying to ask for things
such as the color of the house
what cars are outside and so forth
because we want to obviously again make
sure we're setting up on this wrong that
the correct house
well one of the things
on these type of calls is you know
basically if you're suspect that you
believe the suspect in this situation
the dad comes outside we're going to try
to address him give him commands
um you know to basically surrender to us
right because you think he's a murderer
correct and we have an arrest team and
stuff like that when you also have what
we call long you know long gun coverage
someone with what we call a precision
rifle operator somebody with an ar-15 or
something like that so we've got patrol
officers that carry ars here in tulsa
obviously everybody does and so we get
one set up across the street basically
looking at the front door of what we
believed is this house
and the order that me as a supervisor
that i had to give was if this guy steps
out on the porch
and you know we give him commands to
surrender and he doesn't do that if he
turns to go back inside the house
drop them literally that's it you know
you are authorized to put this guy down
because we think we have this kid inside
underneath the bed and so that was my
decision as a supervisor you know i was
like
at that time that's a tough decision to
make well it you know it's
i was on the swat team at the time i'd
been on probably five or six years
around this time and
obviously well versed in you know
training and you know what we call
tactical operation guidelines things
like that
knowing
what the law allows you to do and stuff
like that and obviously think about the
safety of this kid so the decision
wasn't hard to make but you you know
like even talking about it today and
it's something post right after it
happened i thought about i was like dude
i just gave the
the green light to an officer that hey
if this guy comes on the porch and
doesn't do what he's supposed to do in
terms of going the house you put him
down
and
the more information we kept getting
trying to get from cars the cars didn't
match up to the house we were at the
color of the house didn't match up to
where we were at and we finally
basically just through other you know
putting in calls and stuff like that the
name that they were giving because of
the databases we have we can run utility
checks on residences we can run what we
call
our traces system which is our tulsa
regional record system you run that and
you go
nothing this person's giving matches up
the only thing that matches up is the
address they're giving us and it turned
out to be a complete bogus deal and this
person that had done this had done three
or four of these over a couple weeks in
tulsa and i don't remember if they end
up eventually getting caught but it was
just like all of a sudden they stopped
but with all that being said you say is
it hard to give that decision you know i
i don't have a problem either myself or
given the order for somebody if
something you know if it's a justifiable
deal that we need to do i'm i'd go to
sleep just fine
but think about that had somebody come
out on the front porch that night
and hey tulsa please you know come here
and come here and the guy's like man i
don't know what you're talking about in
turns to go in the house
and boom we end up shooting this guy so
that's the impact the swatting type
calls can have
because it's innocent people's homes
that you are in fact going to yeah so
yeah and i mean it's beyond a prank oh
yeah it's horrible i mean it is you know
it's like i said an 18 year old kid who
thinks it's funny or he's pissed off at
somebody online and
you know
again wasting police resources people
um you know people can get hurt from
these things well i mean um
what i heard was that the average cost
minimum cost to send out a swat team is
something around ten thousand dollars
it's exactly it's a lot it's a lot of
manpower a lot of overtime right for a
kid with a cell phone
or a kid calling over his computer or
stuff so the reason i guess you're
asking why i brought up all that call of
duty stuff right
yeah yeah well you just wanted to get
your handle out there so people could do
friend requests yeah absolutely because
i i have so much time to play call of
duty
but
um
so a case happened two guys were playing
matched
like a matched pair game which a match
pair game is it's two versus two it's
hardcore so in hardcore you can also
shoot i have respect you could shoot
your partners yeah so they're playing
this and they're doing a match game
which they've bet and you want to know
what the wager was well based on the the
guy that charges 10 to 15 dollars for
his swatting and i'm going to say 10 to
15 it was a dollar fifty okay these are
a big piece so these guys these guys
were playing so before you finish your
story i'm going to tell you so here's my
ultimate thing i talked shit about on
call of duty at the end of the game when
somebody is just talking shit it's
usually you know after the game's over
when you're in the little lobby and they
have a horrible stat well it's even if
it's somebody who's really good you know
you motherfucker said y'all suck i
whipped your ass and this and that and
that's usually i say comments can be my
credit score is better
that's all i say in the lobby dude
people start laughing i'm like no my
credit score is better i don't give a
fuck my credit score is better so
the dollar fifty these people are not
concerned about their credit score if
that's what they're wagering well so
these guys wager this game they go and
play um
the guy's teammate shoots him and kills
him
the guy freaks out right and he they
getting a huge yelling match over this
right this is like you and i playing
together it is that is one of the funny
things when you're playing in the game
so you can only communicate with the
people on your team during gameplay and
you have people screaming at each other
right on the same team well yeah we're
not like that we just we just going pew
pew yeah we don't care so he ends up
screaming at him he goes you
motherfucker
i am so pissed at you
i'm gonna have your house swatted tells
the guy this right okay he goes i'm
gonna go i'm gonna find the king of
swatters well
the king of swatters was a twitter
handle for this guy
who was doing the stuff for 10 to 15
bucks a swat so this guy contacts him
and he says hey
my call of duty partner sucks he lost a
match i'm out of buck 50 i'm willing to
pay you 15 or 10 times as much that is
10 times if you can cause him a little
bit of grief
and the guy goes yeah i don't know about
that well his partner catches wind that
he's contacted this guy in the twitter
feed
so since he's contacted this guy on the
twitter feed he can see it in the
twitter oh yeah these are smart people
we're talking about right so
his partner goes listen up king of the
swatters
here's my address come get you some
so
the king of the swatters has a little
bit of an ego he kind of gets off on
doing this he's been taunted
he looks at the guy's address he's in
wichita kansas
and anybody that's been to wichita
kansas knows that btk serial yeah i've
ever heard yeah you have heard of it
again not much else in wichita uh cessna
airplanes
they're out of there it's just like it's
the only town you basically drive
through once you get out of sand springs
oklahoma until you get to denver yeah it
is there's not much the royal is that
one place that bob dole's from
so he ends up calling wichita's police
department he tells him that
he is just his dad has just killed his
mom
similar to my story right this they have
a common script he gets the uh guys he
he gives a description he says i'm still
in the house you need to come over here
and take care of this
well little did the police know that
they were being swatted
so the police
show up at this address
a gentleman opens the door comes out
you guys when you roll deep you roll
deep sure and if you especially on a
call like that yeah if you think
somebody's armed i mean
you're
your job's stressful as hell you know
you have people shooting at you when you
don't expect it so if you do expect them
to be shooting at you i mean you're
ready to go shows up at this house
knocks on the door guy comes out has no
idea what's going on right
because the kid the partner
had given him the wrong address please
unfortunately
this guy comes out the police are there
he turns around and walks back into the
house
he gets shot as he's turning around and
going back in and is killed i just want
so just for everybody listening the
story that i was giving about my
incident
no no i was saying howard and i did not
pre-discuss anything we were going to
talk about on here and it wasn't like we
shared stories so this is just
exactly going to what i had said earlier
this is what
you fear that happens on these type of
calls and this is exactly and when you
were saying that that's what i was like
this is this is horrible so this swatter
ends up
there's a
is it like a felony murder charge no he
got caught he got charged with
involuntary manslaughter okay and ended
up getting he was sentenced to 20 years
in uh federal prison for that okay
i don't know whether he used probably
computer or telephonic device across
like state lines or something like that
i'm imagining that's why it was a
federal deal yeah absolutely but the guy
that did it was a guy named tyler
barreras and he was like basically a 25
year old homeless kid that was doing
this stuff
but this is just
here's what it said it unlocked a new
fear for me like i'm scared of my snakes
right i'm scared of my mama
and now i'm scared as this one so now
you you play with mute on every time now
yeah i don't talk any shit and i'm not
playing any match games to where i have
to put up money and if i do i'm just
like i'm so sorry
that i that i killed you and this is not
an isolated
occurrence one of the things that also
that i read was about a um a gentleman
who was from tennessee and he was a 60
year old man
and uh he was into computers he was
computer scientist and i was into
computers when i was very young so he
was an early adopter of technology is
like what i like to say my girlfriend
she's a little younger than me and she
likes to say that um
that i'm new to computers and i'm like
oh i've been around commodore 64. i was
like i was there when they were coming
yeah i was like i'm not new to computers
yeah i was an early adopter so we have
can we have stuff about this but this
gentleman in tennessee he got on twitter
real early like within the first three
or four months and he ended up with the
twitter handle tennessee
okay which you know that's that's we
could sell that right and he got many
offers for it three to five thousand
dollars like hey you wanna sell
tennessee on twitter no i don't wanna
sell it no i don't wanna sell no i don't
wanna sell it
well
somebody came and asked him hey
you wanna sell and he goes nope i don't
want to sell it he goes well fuck you
i'm going to go ahead and dox you and
put your information out there doxton
put his information out there and a
teenager in the uk
picked up the information and goes huh
all right i'm gonna go ahead and swat
this guy
so
he was a little bit more sophisticated
in what he was saying and the police 911
call has a
young man with a british accent talking
about his father again
has
killed some family members
and he has rigged the entire place
with
pipe bombs
and so the police show up out there this
60 year old man walks out of his house
and he's got a little farm in the
country
he comes out he
has no idea what the hell is going on
the police are there in full force they
go he goes yeah i'm cooperating with you
whatever you need whatever you need i
guess he has a little farm and some
animals and he has a metal gate there
and a fence that surrounds it so he gets
up to the metal gate and police officers
are you guys are a lot smarter than i
mean
the things that we look
well then you look for you retire but
that's that's okay they look they they
see things
they see a lot of things that could be a
threat
and the one thing that the cops saw that
was a threat was the gate because it was
made of pipe and so he was like the guy
goes i'm gonna open the gate he goes
don't open the gate
okay why not he goes don't open the gate
and of course they think that this man
has killed somebody they're
booby-trapped and yeah all of this jazz
well
they were like i want you to climb over
the gate
and the guy goes i can't climb over the
gate i'm 60 years old and i'm overweight
and stuff did he have legs like tinting
he didn't have tank take legs okay but
they said he they were like we'll crawl
under the gate well the gate was about a
foot off the ground and this guy was a
little chunky and he was a little
thicker than a foot and it took some
exertion for the 60 year old man to and
you know i'm telling this story like the
60 year old man's old
16 very old it's not old
no i don't think that this is very old
but this guy wasn't in peak performance
like you and i are he goes to climb
under he didn't go to crossfit eclipse
in tulsa no he didn't at all or ride
mountain bikes at turkey mountain that's
it or play golf at
the place you play that place i play
golf look at the club um
so he goes to climb under the gate ends
up having a massive heart attack and oh
man
so
the
what are you gonna do with a kid that's
in the uk that's done this swatting what
happens to him
do they do
i don't do a warning i'm just guessing
here interpol isn't that what they know
what it's called like for some
international type of stuff to arrest a
person yeah he was actually extradited
to the u.s all right
they're like okay
this ain't the way you play so how do
how do you protect yourself as an
average citizen from this kind of stuff
you can't can you no so uh just kind of
go back in what did they charge him for
i think they um
well while you're looking at that so you
know speaking for oklahoma obviously
every state has a different name for you
know a lot of the laws that are very
similar in nature but here in oklahoma
we have what's called felony murder and
it is
where if you are committing a felony and
because of your actions somebody dies
even it wasn't your intent
obviously if you go shoot at somebody
your intent is to shoot them so that's a
different type of murder
but uh example
you go do a bank robbery you go inside
there or actually it's very similar to
this story right here you go inside to
do a bank robbery you'll have a gun in
there older lady in there has a heart
attack and dies
she died because of the stress of the
bank robbery happening while she by
while you're in there
even though you didn't try to kill her
you're going to be charged another
example that we have that happens quite
a bit let's say you and i are bad guys
we're going to do a robbery at a
convenience store we go in and you know
guns out
we walk through the door convenience
store owner uh it's you know one of
these mom-and-pop places he's prepared
for us he comes in he starts shooting
when we come in
kills one of us and the other one gets
away well guess what the one that got
away is gonna get charged for felony
murder so your homeboy you know my buddy
got killed
but because of our actions is why he was
killed so somebody you know had to do
something we were committing a felony
they had to do something resulted in
that death so that's what we call a
felony murder here okay um and that's
the type of charge for something like
that that would typically happen on both
of the incidents that you gave
now uh to protect yourself
um
you know obviously these things are few
and far in between they don't happen a
lot
well documented stories out there
listen with public records there's so
much of your information out there
i do know um you know there's a couple
different places you can go online to
try to get some of your information
removed
um one of them is called
spokeo.com s-p-o-k-e-o
so you can kind of look yourself up
there and you can uh
fill out the paperwork to remove your
name from the public records
whitepages.com remember the old good old
phone book type of deal there's a
there's one called whitepages.com has a
lot of personal information on there you
can get on there as well and get your
information removed so that way you're
at least minimizing to the best that you
can how much of your information is out
there obviously if you're online don't
share your shit with anybody you know
try to try to minimize how much you can
get released to the public hey with the
white pages thing i got to ask you a
question
do you ever remember going through the
white pages and there was a girl that
you liked and her last name and you
would call all of the phone numbers with
last name asking oh dude i remember
living out in the bay area and the phone
book i mean listen i was a kid we prank
call people right out of phone book you
just random flip through pages you know
pick a name just point finger down and
your buddy had to call it and say some
stupid shit yeah but you never had the
police sent out there no you know well
we didn't yeah we didn't ask for police
to show up we weren't that sophisticated
this is back in the era of you know is
your refrigerator running
you know that type of stupid stuff yeah
there was a lot i had a great time
before caller id came in uh uh cranking
my mom because she was an accountant no
and i would call her accounting officer
yeah this is leroy bartholomew i need to
talk to pam for a minute
i got like two or three of her
receptionists i got through tomorrow
that's a bomb that way and they were
like oh howard or something okay so the
kid the british kid ended up getting 60
months it didn't say what he's charged
with so that so he got did he get
charged federally also uh yes well
probably if it's in months that's
usually how the feds do their stuff so
that's five years federal yeah yep so he
ended up getting that but again just
fascinating stuff there's
so so most of the both of those cases
that i think you just mentioned they
were both federal i mean i'm assuming
that one was federal i think the one
before that you said federal and what it
is is if you're using you know you
commit computer crimes
those it's very easy for federal
prosecutors to pick those type of cases
up because you know you're using
computers uh stuff that goes over state
lines you know telephones things like
that are very easily
uh picked up or adopted by federal
prosecutors for prosecution
well man i had like 30 things we're
gonna have to do another one of these
because these are
30 things to talk about we talked about
swatting these are lovely and we talked
about tank tank well we've got what two
and a half minutes what else we got oh
we can talk about um well you know cars
are getting expensive right now right so
it was gas yeah so uh
a million dollars worth of ford pickups
were stolen a pickup for people who
aren't in oklahoma is a kind of a car
with a
thing in the back that's open to the
elements to which you can put stuff on
most of these devices are used in
oklahoma to be jacked up and um have big
tires put on well they usually you haul
around your family in the back right
with no seat belts or just freely
sitting back there you have a couple
dogs
four kids
just running around the back of the bed
as you're driving down the highway hey
is it against the law to have somebody
in the bed of a truck man you know i've
been asked that a million times and i am
not a traffic guru so i i don't know if
it is uh
listen i don't know i don't know i can
tell you what trafficking cocaine is in
oklahoma
but you don't know i can tell you what
the federal charge is for being a felon
in possession of a firearm and so forth
but i don't ever ride in the back of a
pickup truck
man i know what california shake up yes
i have a thousand times no back then i
have i i remember doing it uh with like
uh the old camper shell on the back you
know back in that era when those were
around that was just the first suvs
that's all that was yeah the first those
early 84 four runners you can haul that
around but the pinnacle of trucks around
here
if you want to be cool i mean this
seriously if you want to get a lot of
looks from guys around here you would
get the ford raptor
right that's true the f-150 ford raptor
yep with like 900 horsepower they're
strong with those shelby trucks too yeah
somebody with the price of uh cars right
now this isn't that many but somebody
stole them a million dollars worth of
those so what was it like literally
yeah it's probably not that many yeah no
they're uh they retail for the base
price on seventy thousand dollars but
with the dealer markup now i'm sure that
they were yeah they stole like eight
cars but that made national news which i
thought was funny because everybody
around here every every time i get in a
group of guys that are truck owners they
oh man you seen that ford raptor
attorney yeah those things are fast man
it looks like an episode of king of the
hill along i'm talking around well i'm
gonna drop this real quick we got about
30 seconds left but old phil hawkins
yeah a real phil he's got a ford raptor
he's got a real nice one we took a hell
of a fast road trip to that from tulsa
to kansas city in that thing
uh but also corey scott he's got a
raptor that's his hunting truck that's
his hunting truck that's his hunting
what's he running to deer with him
literally he runs over them runs over
them yeah so that's his hunting truck a
ford raptor see i knew this would be
very pertinent to what we're speaking of
here in oklahoma so hey sean that was
fun i appreciate it we'll hit these
other stories next time yeah i think
we'll probably do two or three more i've
got a lot of stories that we need to
talk about all right that's it for
cocktails and cocktails we'll catch you
on the next one all right out
[Music]